you know everybody knows yeah alibaba to
buy stuff that already exists
where do i go to create new things
well that's why we created gemba to help
people do that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm with henrik johansson a serial
entrepreneur who co-founded and built
the product company boundless into a 100
million dollar company
apparently he is the co-founder and ceo
of gamba a product development platform
and marketplace and the executive
producer of final product a reality tv
show incubated at gamba
he was previously a co-founder and board
member of outbound engine and before
that he was the president of everyday
wealth and co-founder and president of
creditland
johansen specializes in
technology-enabled services marketplaces
and software as a service he is an
expert on scaling startups building
world-class teams culture and scalable
processes and infrastructure and has
been featured in forbes entrepreneur
austin business journal and was named
counselors 2017 person of the year
[Music]
henrik johansson welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you very much for joining
me today how are you for having me
pleasure's all night well well the
pleasure really is mine i'd say you know
you're talking about an amazing career
in product development and
and quite a few companies under your
belt you're so entrepreneur today the
ceo of gamba previously the ceo and
co-founder of boundless network
which sold
[Music]
and they which was acquired for its
services and part of development and and
you're continuing along that same path
but but you've been you know co-founder
and board member for for companies for
quite some time and so i'm excited to
sort of pick your brain about your your
personal journey with product
development and it's something that you
know we learn and we learn in school we
learn in accelerators and incubators and
but it doesn't it hasn't seemed like
there were too many
too many products out there that that
made it a better process for us tangibly
and so henrik thank you very much for
coming here
yeah thank you
good fortune
tell me a little bit about yourself
getting into product development where
where where did that passion come from
and julie
yeah i mean i grew up in sweden
um did not have entrepreneurial parents
uh they still don't understand what i'm
doing today that i could
surprise the amaze buyers but
came to the states you know i was a
management consultant and i lived in the
bay area uh in san francisco during the
late 90s when the dot com thing happened
and uh started a company uh with with
some friends and
early on i was intrigued by marketplaces
you know how how marketplaces can create
markets and how software platforms can
you know revolutionize some old uh
industry that hasn't been revolutionized
uh so the first company was credit land
it was an online lending marketplace
bringing together you know all all
different types of credit and lending uh
to consumers
and you know it did we were a little bit
ahead of our time and we got stuck in
the
in the com crash and unfortunately the
company did not survive so
early on now um i learned a lot about
you know um things don't always go the
way
the way where you want them to go but do
you you know it's not a failure until
you if you don't learn anything so
like you said continue to do startups
venture funded startups ever since and
i think again that's my fifth they're
working on right now like you said it's
focused on helping other people develop
new products
so if we're looking at the world of
product development today
and
we're looking at specifically the way
that that people find resources
to design manufacture think through
and market their their products so where
what are some of the
sort of you know the bottlenecks in this
process that you've identified
yes so the the huge market that that
we've seen right is that big companies
they have internal product development
teams they have engineers and designers
and then they have supply chain experts
compliance experts so you know they have
the resources to do it but the
interesting thing that's happened over
the last decade or so is that
the barriers to entry to start a
e-commerce company have been lowered
drastically lowered right through amazon
and shopify and others you can literally
start an e-commerce company in a day
today
oh
but what nobody has done though is lower
the barriers to enter to create new
products now to to go through the
product development journey sure you can
go on a bulb and buy something that
already exists from a catalog
but since there are more and more
sellers now that that's not a viable
business model anymore so what we're
seeing is that all these
millions of new sellers that are coming
in and want to start ecommerce business
they have to differentiate their
products
in order to be successful just to
survive and thrive
but there is nowhere to go you know
everybody knows yeah alibaba to buy
stuff that already exists
where do i go to create new things
well that's where we create a gamba to
help people do that because it is a this
is a pretty complex process if you think
of going all the way from you know
sketch to the back of a napkin you have
an idea
well now you can have to come up with a
design and then you have to you know
turn that into real spec with
cad drawings and things like that now
you gotta start talking to factories and
figure out if you can actually make that
product for for an affordable mount and
then you have to go through the whole
sampling and you know the production
process and the logistics and all that
sits it it's it's a long and arduous
journey
and part of always started the companies
that we saw a lot of small small
businesses you know made small mid-sized
businesses
they they fail on that journey it's it's
it's enough that one of the steps go
wrong right and you end up with a
container full of products
that doesn't work the way it's supposed
to
and that may be you know that failure
may be fatal for small business they
can't afford to have a whole hundred
thousand dollar production run go wrong
or have a you know have a product
recalled or uh you know creating some
products investing in the product
assignments that they can't make for the
for the amount that's that's required so
we saw that there was a huge need
for someone to help small mid-sized
businesses develop new products and
that's how we created the gamba
yeah and so part of the idea here is to
create this marketplace right where you
can bring in people from from the diff
these different
skill sets to support the product
development process of these businesses
and but it's like what you are
describing here is that some of the
pitfalls along the journey you know
trust is one of them
the ability to have a relationship with
them is one of them so
how does that get compensated for in in
a more
global economy type of marketplace where
where people are interacting mainly
digitally not necessarily from the same
place or culture is there
how big of a factor is trust here and in
partnering with others in the product
development life cycle
yep it's a great question um
and you know the interesting part is
there's this distrust on both sides you
know often
in the west we will distrust the the
factories in china wherever it might be
but but there's a lot of businesses
overseas that have been screwed by
western companies too in this process
and in many times it's not from ill
intent it's it's about lack of
understanding and lack of alignment and
cultural differences uh
so that's what gamba creates this
trusted network it's almost like it's
all nation and ecosystem of trusted
vetted partners
that have agreed that we're going to
work under this specific protocol they
agree up front on the years that are
going to work together here's what we're
committed to doing in a certain time
frame
that you know if you're going on alibaba
millions of listings it's not hard to
find a factory but often you don't even
know if we're talking to is the factory
or is it some trading company or or a
sourcing agent or or just someone who
put up you know shopping listing
you know within dembo we we're
completely transparent we share the
address and the information with the
factory
with the customer they can speak to each
other through our platform
and we're 100 transparent about the
purchase orders and you know what the
cost is
uh so you know our goal is not to be
sourcing agents our goal is to be the
platform through which people conduct
business uh and and develop trusted
relationship with the manufacturers and
partners
so walk me through
the
the process that a the business may go
into
may may go into the platform they're
starting to onboard and what what really
is their relationship
with the platform at this point with
gamba so how did they go from the from
the having the problem to actually
solving it with gamba
yep
yeah let's let's let's use
an example for example let's say
somebody come to us and they have this
idea they want to create a set of
headphones
but they was they would have solar cells
on top of them so that these headphones
never run out of battery right
well so we going when they come to us
with that we go in our database and
immediately based on the product they're
trying to create we know all the steps
that you have to go through from
sketching to design 2d rendering 3d
renderings from component uh
manufacturing component sourcing and
then through the whole production
process what you need to do as far as qc
compliance testing certifications all
that so our platform creates this
project plan basically these are all the
steps you have to go through
then it goes into this talent networks
that we have where we have thousands of
engineers designers
uh factories all over the world
and um through our algorithm identify
the very best match
so if you're making these headphones
you'll find some an industrial designer
that works at bose maybe or skull candy
or something like that
and they'll work find somebody who
create solar cells that's you know uh
samsung or dyson or something so you put
together the very best team that you can
find in the world to work with this
project and then you know
you take their billing rates and create
a combined bill rate for the customer so
it becomes very affordable for them to
go through the sign phase
and then we do the same thing on the you
know once you get to the end of the
design you have this what's called a dfm
design for manufacturing phase to make
sure that
what you're designing is actually can be
manufactured
in a reasonable time frame and for an
affordable cost
and then we go through the same process
basically with the factories we get
multiple factories they get to bid for
the for the project
helps them negotiate the best deal with
that factory
and then they can manage the whole
production process through the platform
so when the product hit the production
line their qc people showing up on the
in the factory in whatever country it is
taking pictures going through the tests
protocols
uploading pictures and videos of the
tested product
so that the customer wherever they are
can can basically go into the gambler
platform to see oh here are all the
tasks that
that they went through and the products
actually working the way it's supposed
to be working and you know
check that box before
uh it's loaded and shipped to to
the customer's destination
so going back to the decision
of of full transparency it seemed like
that was a
there was a part of it that you were
that you were quite proud of and i think
it's amazing and i'm just wondering how
does that work in in the business
setting where you know a marketplace
you know one of the biggest assets of a
marketplace is the fact that it has the
information of the two sides and and it
allows the two sides to engage on its
platform because if they go to other
platforms then i mean then you're not
really part of the
of the process anymore so so how do you
balance or what are the trade-offs in
this case
between this this transparency that
you're talking about versus
you know needing to
be to be the platform where they
actually engage on
and where you can monetize on that
yeah
yeah like like you you point out you
know circumvention is always an issue
with most marketplaces uh particularly
talent marketplaces is people are
worried that people that are around it
what we found is that um it's not that
much of an issue in in what we're doing
uh you know first if you look at on the
design side
part of the value here is that the
platform identifies how to orchestrate
the collaboration between these
resources right the typical small
business would not know
how to direct the work of an electrical
engineer and mechanical engineer and
designer for how for them to work
together what deliverables to create
what specs that they need to provide to
the factory so
we we haven't really seen any any
circumvention in that stage
and then with the factory our our fees
the early the goals our fees are so
level
that it doesn't make sense for the
customer to circumvent us right if they
don't speak chinese or or
uh they speak uh
yeah
spanish for the mexican factory we can
provide this this uh safe trusted way to
do business right and also manage
the payments
it's a scary thing to send fifty
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars wire that's a factory somewhere
else in the world without really knowing
what's going to happen right so we we
want to be that trusted place where
people feel comfortable and it's safe
and it's uh there's very little risk in
conducting business
and today that's been successful you
know we don't see a lot of attrition uh
or circumvention at all
so so a lot of these um a lot of these
players in the marketplace that you have
are actually
you know they're providing very high
value orders right it's not a
it's not just like freelancers hey can
you do this gig and if it doesn't work
out and then in an hour i'll stop the
contract right here i mean you're
talking about orders that can get
pretty high how do you vet
so how do you know that the people that
you have are actually high quality it
sounds like this is a really challenging
problem
yeah we and we made that mistake i think
in the beginning where where sometimes
our customer does not quite appreciate
that the time and the cost it takes to
develop and create a brand new product
right so
we had some folks starting in in the
early years starting the process
they paid ten thousand dollars let's say
to create a design
only to find that they actually didn't
have enough money for for the tooling or
you know to place the purchase order
so
right nowadays we do a lot of education
on the front end with our customers the
first in every proposal that we present
we show them here's how long it's going
to take you to do this here are all the
fees that it's going to cost
and you know this is probably about the
time you're going to be able to get the
product on the shelf because we we like
particularly some of the you know
inexperienced
companies they figured out this is going
to cost five grand i'm gonna have
product in three weeks and that's just
not the case it just doesn't work that
way in in manufacturing
so today we take pride in educating
people on on the process and we actually
still drop disqualified a lot of folks
uh if they don't have the the means to
actually go through the entire process
and we take pride in that you know one
of our core values always do the right
thing and i think that's the that's the
right thing to do
um to build trust and transparency in in
what we're doing
awesome so from your from your side of
you know product development life cycles
you know
for young entrepreneurs that are that
are creating products whether they're
software based or hardware based and
you know i think our whole life is just
one product development life cycle but
you know what are some or what are some
things that you've learned about
yourself for or about this world that
that would be relevant for us to keep in
mind as we just go on our journeys
things that would be relevant for any i
guess sort of situation for product
development
yeah i think you know
the world of software product
development is pretty well understood
and you know
silicon valley and course the world
spend a lot of time developing tools and
collaboration software and
make that very accessible for folks
nobody blinks an eye to you know bring
in a
java engineer from the ukraine or or you
know wherever they might be that's
that's understood nobody's done that
really for hardware product development
right so that's again we're trying to
create this platform for that
and i see that you know similar to i
think software development if you don't
if you're not very clear up front of
what you're trying to develop
odds are things are not going to go very
well further down so we spend a lot of
time up front to really understand
what are you trying to do as a customer
what are your objectives well what do
you want with this product is it's like
a you know as a luxury product really
high-end way and you need to be
completely different than anything else
on the market
or are you more e-commerce amazon
sellers you're just trying to put little
twists on
an existing product so you can add this
to your
uh to your current catalog right so
having
a clear understanding for that because
you know if you're really trying to
create a unique product it can take a
year to go through the whole journey
particularly if it has complexity it has
little impartial electronics it's gonna
require prototyping a lot of testing but
if all you need is like another
insulated cup that you want to you know
sell on amazon
well we can make that happen in a couple
months you just create some some small
change to design or packaging or
branding or colors
and you can have that product on the
shelf for much lower cost in much slower
time frames so
i think that's that's key in in software
and hardware product well but be very
clear up front about what you're trying
to achieve and what your what your
budget is
and to really align on expectations uh i
think that's that's the key and so
you've still chosen to to be here for
quite some time and to start another
company in this space
really you know i asked you before what
how did you get into product development
but why are you here now
so after so long
you know what what makes you decide yes
i'm going to also my new company
i'm going to be in the in this similar
space what led to that decision
yeah i always had this you know my mom
was was always
fighting for
for uh
the right thing to do she you know she
she fought the referendum in sweden as
nuclear power she worked for amnesty
international we were writing letters to
you know dictators from the world so i
always had this desire inside me that i
should be
should do something good with my life
and have a positive impact and
and while my prior companies i think
we're all
good and created a great work
environment
i never felt like they were changing the
world right for the better
uh they created you know good jobs and
good career for people
so
doing this this one which i think is my
last one probably
i wanted to be something that that could
have a huge impact on the world and i do
believe that
you know our vision is a democracize
product creation and and unlock
virtually a limited
entrepreneurial equity all over the
world i mean i'm sure there are
brilliant minds in israel and you know
in africa or in sweden that have ideas
but they just don't know what to do with
them and these great ideas should be
brought to the world and it could help a
lot of people and and make make the
world a better place and we're also
the big thing we're launching this year
is this new sustainable more
eco-friendly ways to develop products so
we believe that
as more and more product development
moves to
smaller companies we really have an
opportunity to to not just help people
make
better products but make products better
in a way that's better for the planet
and the environment so
that's what gets me up in the morning
that's what drives me that's you know
yeah sure we want to build a successful
very large company but i think we also
have the chance to develop a category
defining company that that's going to
help a lot of people
um
and in today's world more more people
you know the great resignation are gen
z's they don't want to work like their
parents did for everybody wants to be
their own entrepreneur and i think gemba
can be a
an important player and that's in that
ecosystem in that new world
henrik sounds uh sounds really cool and
i love the vision i love the
the motivation and the execution thank
you very much for being here this was
very very enjoyable uh best of luck with
gamba and make a positive impact i look
forward to trying it out myself and uh
thank you very very much
thank you have a great day appreciate it
fantastic